for his kidnap rape and abduction of
sarah everard his lawyer had argued for
some mercy but the judge jailed wayne
cousins for the rest of his life
and so cousins became the first police
officer to be given a whole life
sentence he shook as he heard his fate
the judge didn't mince his words
you have irretrievably damaged the lives
of sarah everard's family and friends
you have very considerably added to the
sense of insecurity that many have
living in our cities perhaps
particularly women when traveling by
themselves and especially at night
the officer's former boss scotland yards
commissioner watched as cousins was
sentenced
i am absolutely horrified
that this man used his position of trust
to deceive and coerce sarah
and i know you all are too
i absolutely know that there are those
who feel their trust in us is shaken
i recognize that for some people a
precious bond of trust has been damaged
i am
so sorry
sarah's family described her as a
beautiful young woman in looks and
character
they would hold her safe in their hearts
wayne cousins held a position of trust
as a police officer and we are outraged
and sickened that he abused this trust
in order to lure sarah to her death
the world is a safer place with him
imprisoned
but could cousins have been stopped
before he abducted sarah
three days before he was suspected of
indecent exposure at a mcdonald's
restaurant in kent
the met police were investigating
the force says that crown prosecutors
are now considering charges in the case
while the police watchdog the iopc
continues to investigate whether the met
could have done more at the time and
take an early action against cousins
there was growing pressure on the force
and its boss
there are questions serious questions
that will need to be answered by the
metropolitan police from the minute that
sarah went missing these were clear
points and questions and challenges that
were put to the metropolitan police and
to the met commissioner directly
police continue to investigate cousins
but have found no evidence of other
crimes they appeal to the public and his
former colleagues to report any
suspicions around him
a man the judge labelled warped selfish
and brutal
martin brunt sky news